parce que d'ici un an je vais voler son
poste de partant jean philippe baril
guérard vous êtes comédien auteur
metteur en scène nous est aussi la voix
de radio canada
pour commencer ce cinq minutes avec
pourriez-vous faire un trait prolonger
pourquoi on vous identifie au début du
très prolongée ce sera exactement le
début de cinq minutes avec ses biens je
commence à être un bon but en huit ans
j'ai adoré dévorer votre nouveau grand
match parce avec la romande d'été faut
se le dire mais avant je jouais sur
légère de plein on va on va revenir à ça
mais avant je vais commencer avec vos
débuts parce que votre rêve à votre
sortie de l'école de théâtre du cégep de
saint-hyacinthe était de devenir
comédien est-ce que c'est aux grèves qui
était nourri par vos parents ou cette
horreur qui a été nourrie par la révolte
envers vos parents certainement pas mes
parents parce que mes parents sont
vétérinaire fait que c'est la plateforme
est tombé un pont entre les deux proches
de l'arbas certains de gamme mais
certainement pas professionnellement
ouais non mais ça a été assez grand
l'école secondaire j'avais été j'avais
vraiment des profs super qui m'ont
intéressé à la littérature j'avais une
troupe de théâtre par plus d'une troupe
de théâtre à l'école secondaire qui
était vraiment cool
je pense que lyon 2 après tour c'est
d'école j'ai fait l'école des femmes au
tnm a démarré j'ai quand même été
chanceux j'ai eu des super beau contrat
ou à la télévision virginie virginie
s'est rapidement
je travaille encore un peu comme comédie
je trouve encore un peu tous acheté
moins de théâtre
parce que je peux en faire dans son sûr
ça donne ça donne comme ça que je dirais
que là son côté écriture dans ce
monastère mathieu pas sic
gj pas au mieux le discours donné non
plus arrivons aux cards à l'entrevue
avec votre dernier roman autres
démolitions il ya des humoristes qui
vont grincer des dents parce que c'est
l'histoire d'un raphaël mascotte
humoriste fictif mais quand même qui
baigne dans le monde de l'humour un
monde de drogue de sexe et d'alcool
ben écoutez c'est en vain que je
prétends pas que ces documents par dick
et c'est la réalité que tous les
humoristes ça c'est vrai pour chacun de
mes livres je m'intéresse à une portion
de la réalité mais c'est certain que tu
ais je suis aussi partie de lieux
communs que des choses sur lesquelles il
me reste le même font des blagues
il ya beaucoup de demandes initiales jo
que j'ai entendu moi même la bouche du
meurice que j'ai inséré dans le livre
parce que parce que ça servait un autre
mon propos aussi généralement quand je
chante elle écrit un livre je
m'intéresse à ce qui est grinçant
puisque et d'actes puisqu'ils sont parce
que ça fait des livres plus intéressant
quand même réalisation de l'impression
que pour créer de l'humour faut prendre
la drogue
c'est drôle à une question de me pose
d'un artiste même en général c'est six
fois quel point la consommation de
substances psychoactives quelle qu'elle
soit est intrinsèquement liée à
production artistique depuis tellement
longtemps à dimanche deux remarques en
jour des autres tu vois plus d'alcool
et si en train d'écrire puis que je
manque un peu de motivation jamal
m'enjoint puis je veux chapelle me
donner le courage nécessaire pour écrire
deux heures de plus qu'il ya dix ans
quand même votre personnage principal il
souffre beaucoup justement coup dans sa
conservation le sait la difficulté à
quoi que ça va être le remplaçant minuit
dans ce cas ce que l'on peut vraiment
parler de consommation problématiques
ceci est absolument certain
puis le problème aussi c'est quand on
est dans un milieu comme ça où la
consommation est normalisé il ya
personne qui va lever un flacon fin et
je pense que cette personne là est une
consommation d'alcool de drogues
problématique parce que tout le monde et
l'autre qui peut la seule différence
c'est que il y en a qui vont peut-être
est capable d'être des alcooliques
fonctionnel alors que d'autres non et
les questions d'agression sexuelle dans
l'autre demolition man que ça parle du
monde de l'humour un peu je peux c'est
l'actualité qui nous a rattrapés c'est
vous qui avez rattrapé l'actualité mais
vous avez été conseillé par rosalie
vaillancourt aux démolitions donc
qu'est-ce que vous visez aux moindres
est que parler du milieu du mot si je
mentionnais pas au moins sept ans j'ai
l'oeil
j'aurais eu l'impression d'ignorer
l'éléphant dans la pièce après ce chalet
pas que l'éléphant allait être aussi
gros puis autant proche de la vitrine
dont je pense qu'il ya des gens qui
pourraient wii se sentir visés mais les
personnes qui pourraient se sentir
attaqué par le livre sont peut-être
celle qui pourrait avoir des
comportements problématiques parce que
je dis pas que tous les humoristes sont
des agresseurs potentiels
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est des
personnages qui ont trop de pouvoir qui
crissent parles tu dis ce pouvoir là
pour avoir des comportements
problématiques s'est volontairement ou
non dans la démolition il est question
aussi d'une grande peine d'amour est
chez vous avez aussi traité dans faux
départ notre web série et j'ai presque
tout cette inspiration levier d'une
expérience personnelle parce que vous
avez participé à une étude à
l'université mcgill sur les relations
amoureuses qui échoue oui si vous êtes
nourrit de ça ben oui complètement
baisse exercée à prix coûtant ainsi une
vieille histoire quand même qui datent
d'ailleurs
comme certes c'est en fait surtout c'est
que ça va quand même le guéré et ça m'a
permis de
des capable d'envisager relations
amoureuses dans son entièreté avec une
fin où il ya plus disons cette violence
là dans les sentiments purs ou la hache
de guerre est enterrée
puis qu'on arrive à passer à autre chose
même si dans le roman je dirais que le
passage à autre chose et quand même
gorges et d'amertume et de ressentiment
jean philippe baril guérard merci
beaucoup merci l'inflation
[Musique]